xqc versus stardosh the winner of group
b with the white pieces versus the second
place player of group a sarah i'm gonna call my
brother because we have like the same name so
now we're technically related okay
you please all right bishop to c4
and i don't know if he has anything prepped but
his development looks pretty solid so far but
he has been grinding so much and it's definitely
been paying off in his games exactly yeah i like
to call this uh a reverse london everything comes
back to the london but all right it's always about
the london i like the setup that stardust has
gone for because the bishop on c4 can be dangerous
pointing at that f7 spot after e6 you make your
spawn structure more solid and the king safer
the problem is this knight is not very protected
only by queen which means
you're kind of vulnerable
oh wait a minute queen
he gonna go for it now this is no longer
protected though do i care i mean if he did go
queen after you just bishop b7 right
counteracting right away yes that would
be a good response but sardosh has to find it
so let's see first of all i'm gonna go for it
i like it putting him under pressure okay he is
ready to push his e pawn to e5 and that would
mean that both the knight on f6 and the rook
on a8 would be hanging but unfortunately for
him star deutsche immediately plays the
best response bishop to b7 another pawn
is pinned you cannot push e5 because
that would be as we know we all know
it yeah the thing with these moves is like box box
called them they're serotonin moves it looks nice
because he has this one move threat but now he
pretty much just helped black develop and now his
queen's a little bit pinned okay he chose to offer
the trade which is also good you want to trade
when you're up material but i'm not sure that he
should allow them before so i agree with you that
trading overall it could be beneficial to him but
knife bishop takes eight takes before that bottom
b4 will be vulnerable and queen to b5 would attack
both the bishop on b7 and the pawn on b4 so xqc
has a chance to win the pawn back if he spots that
although queen b5 queen e7 that's still not over
but it would make sardosh's life more difficult
to develop the knight from b8 at least it is
exactly what you're saying he's a little bit down
so he needs to get an attack going and this could
be the opportunity for that and i can fork this oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah move queen here and fork that
those knight frogs are good ideas
but unfortunately it's not happening
regarding the square and now rook c8 that is the
best move that sardoche has found is that what i
can do here wow he's gonna trade he's into it
is he oh he's gonna go for it oh my goodness
kendra we could bring our board back and show
what's happening in this position with that c5
knight unfortunately for xqc this is now pinned
through the c5 through the diagonal knight to
a6 as yet another attacking piece to what's
going on on this c5 square that's the key
square here that's the key piece the c5 knight
is going to fall there's not another piece that
white can bring here to the defense the d4 knight
unfortunately is unable to guard their body on c5
you cannot protect it yeah queen b5 was the only
way he has the same situation when he pinned this
queen earlier and now we can't save the piece it's
getting really tough he doesn't even have any like
tactics try to stack oh okay is playing knight to
d7 to try to bait sardo but he's losing his rook
played that so quick he didn't even have to
double check he was so confident that he's taking
the queen and then the rook so both queens are
off of the board but this is now an extra rook for
sardosh yeah i mean look at he looks like he's at
a serious chester right now he is so focused you
know when like half your face is covered by your
hands you're in your zone he's been killing it
now the rook is gone for the two nights and
what remains on the board is still unfortunately
very very tough for xqc it's two extra pieces
and four pawns four best phones for ourselves
we're going all right okay they did trade how to
catch up here well okay and the stalemate chances
are looking better and better what can i say we
gotta push that honey there we go now it's just
the king against the world but i i don't think
i don't know if his dreams are gonna come true
let's see if it's gonna be stalemate or checkmate
we are just a few moves away from seeing the
reality if quinter don't lose it well he shouldn't
bring the queen that close he brings the king in
and now it's checkmate on the person first game no
mercy at all wow so yeah excuse you really threw
everything he had for that stalemate but sardoche
played very clean that was a killer game saradosh
won the first game meaning that xqc is in a must
win situation he has to win if he doesn't win
eliminated the london system android's
already getting excited let's see the
gm he car preparation this is the game
i've been looking forward to man because
i don't play a single other opening as white
except the london system so when i see it
i get really excited because it's you
know the one thing i've studied a lot
all right so far so good knight to c6 is
the move that he car was showing to xqc
with the setup being e6 and bishop to d6 that's
the issue this f4 push whether it was the best or
not it has prevented the gm recovery preparation
where they mainly were focusing on positions with
the trade of bishops now the trade of the bishop
for the e5 knight how do you see the opening of
the f-file in this system i i think i mean this
is okay i i think these pawns are pretty strong
and that now we have the bishop pair sometimes
i get really annoyed when you know they copy you
and then they come do the same thing and
get their own pawns and then even push a 5-2
but i don't know if xqc is going to come for the
center yeah so the hard thing here and i was going
to ask you what do you think the best plan for xqc
to develop is because his pieces are all pretty
passive and all bunched up together and retreated
already it's tough you're right with the knight on
d7 the way of the bishop oh f6 though i think
i was gonna say i think you need to try to to
explode that central structure of white f6 is the
way to go but bishop h4 by sardos immediately to
pin the pawn he is so fast no this is yeah this
is great because his pieces could not develop
anywhere he has to break through somewhere but
sardosa is playing these fantastic moves so fast
pushing the pawn to g5 would be too committal
he should definitely not weaken his kingdom g5
okay i mean um maybe it can still turn out well
but i feel like this is too committal yeah now
just xqc's king is almost naked and afraid look
at all these holes yeah so now it's up to sardosh
maybe he's gonna see this idea try to prevent
it and play something safe like we're treating
his bishop or even more aggressive i wonder i
guess he doesn't have any sac idea like queen h5
take the bishop give some checks and clean
up his pawns there's a lot of ideas for white
wait a second he won the first game so if he
finds a way in which he can force a perpetual
you would be claiming the match so it's
it makes a lot of sense for him to look
for queen h5 queen g6 and try to give perpetual
yeah actually i think this is a perpetual because
king f8 queen check and here then we have a
mate threat so so there actually is a force
well if they take the bishop though so queen
h5 is an interesting name i think you have just
solved the match if he spots queen to h5 which
either is with a really strong attack for white
or if the bishop is accepted it's a perpetual
check for white that's all that sardosh needs
the next stage to the semi-finals he plays instead
which is which is very ambitious but it may not be
oh my god it's now the advantages in black side
i think maybe the plan is f5 but the eval bar
took a big drop i think he has stubbed into the
sacrifice i was trying to make knight takes e5
you've been oh oh the knight one not even the f5
okay let's play it out live so that when d takes
the other knight takes and now the queen and
the bishop are hanging and if you drop the queen
back to e2 to guard the d3 bishop then the h4
bishop is taken so you cannot guard both bishops
wow wow okay i don't want to miss it let's
see if he's gonna if xqc is gonna find it
yeah f5 was a little bit of a safer move
still blocking the attack but that was a
really complicated tactic there let's go board
back and show what's happening because stardust
had to realize that the bishop was gonna be lost
so he places a knight on f3 and then takes on h4
if we just roll back one move i was really worried
again about that queen appearing near the king
so instead of knight takes h4 which happened
instantly i thought sardosh could have gone for
your idea with the perpetual queen to g6 again and
that's better on h7 so that that square is guarded
but these are tiny details that are very difficult
to spot when you're in the midst of the game and
it's such a complex messy position knight takes
h4 makes sense too to try to attack the king let's
see if xqc will bring more pieces to the king side
you need to get your rook and queen involved rook
to g8 for instance would be very logical and all
that sardoche has is a pawn to compensate for it
not much especially considering that it's not a
past pawn they're stacked as we say not doubled
exactly stacked pawns oh and now g4 offering the
pawn i don't know if stardust miscalculated it
that there are two pieces of black attacking
that square yes he takes the pawn wow
oh he was planning to win it back but i
mean black can just defend his pawn here
he might have miscalculated that now there's
h5 push wow the pawn and the rook on g3
is stuck so it's not only that he
lost the player you can't go anywhere
the phone on its own wouldn't be that much of a
disaster but the fact that you cannot move your
rook ever how will he activate the g3 rook oh no i
was gonna say just has to watch out for this night
check he's been preparing but we all right oh okay
so excuse he did step into the night fork but it's
not the end of the world if if he will take one
of the minor pieces for it so he can either take
on g6 or move the king and then take back on f8
yeah there's there's a few i think even after
i think he has already made his decision before
we could have listened and he does take on g6
but now he has to be careful with those paws
the h5 pawn is hanging and if he loses that
pawn the g4 pawn two will fall yeah he only
has one way to defend his pawn bishop e8 he
right now even though he just lost exchange he's
still doing much better because he has this past
pawn here but he can't drop these pawns yes he's
got two minor pieces for the rook but he has to
guard the pawns and you're right andra it's not so
easy to find bishop e8 or or something tricky with
the knight jumps if if he gets over to to f5 but
that's way too dank knight he's seven to then go
knight oh he's dropping them these were the key
the key to success oh no oh and now it's back
in white's favor the g3 rook was completely dead
and now it's back in the game after the g4 pawn
he's breaking free from the chains of this pawn
and taking two pawns almost and there goes another
one oh man oh no and the issue with the king to h6
is that after rook age wow or bishop g4 there will
be checkmate patterns too now yeah we got the
rook roller here holding back the king we just
have to take this pawn wow what a turn of events
excuse me with the piece of but he did not see
that night for coming rook fade would have been a
logical move if it wasn't for the tactical pattern
and now this should be mating too brook takes g4
king goes back to h6 and this cover check mate
and if king to f5 and now it's just
made in one oh my goodness yeah
man the rage and the happiness he
wins his quarterfinals 2-0 against
sqc moves on to the semi-finals well
it was very very stressful because
i knew xqc was really good in open position
and so otherwise so i could get punished if
i go for tactics so well i i tried to close it
up a bit uh i knew he had the preparation for my
london system by kyro just before the stream
but sadly i had my coach telling me exactly
how to actually contact this so i'm
really sorry but my coach won on this one
is that a shout out to blitzstream kevin vordey
i must admit i would have never found it by myself
uh that was kevin kevin body yeah sorry sorry i'm
really sorry but the game was really intense i put
myself in a so hard situation in the white game
and you you did so well with your pawns i was in
so big trouble and well i i gave up my my bishop
and went like okay maybe my maybe my knight we
will do the job and he did at the end so i'm proud
that well that was a bit lucky yeah the bishop
was stuck on the left side of the map and uh
i'm just kidding yeah i thought uh the bishop and
the queen were uh were like stack uh upper left
but the only thing is that uh at mid there's like
a four tread i could have done that i didn't see
and the computer kept saying it wrong wrong
like he didn't want me to do it but i i i
didn't see it again get aggressive are you
talking about the night fork or in the very
first game yeah the night sacrifice to knight take
night the two of you have been on a huge grind for
the whole event as you said xqc uh you started
basically pogchamps we we can thank thank to you
and the collaboration with you and hikaru that the
entire chess boom started and the the series the
pogchamps series grew out of that collaboration
and now you are here for your third poke gyms
unfortunately will need to say goodbye to you but
will we see you be back for [ __ ] chance four
yeah yeah it'll be good it'll be good when i
come back i'll be uh stronger than ever and i'll
uh i'll take the crown then we'll be awesome
to get to every match yep okay thank you guys
you